هذا وقد اثار اعلان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بانه ابلغ اداره بايدن رفضه
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه بعد نهايه الحرب في
غزه اثار موجه انتقادات حاده لدى العديد
من المسؤولين الامريكيين حيث قالت شبكه ان
بي سي الامريكيه ان معارضه نتنياهو لقيام
دوله فلسطينيه قد تؤدي الى تعقيد مصادقه
مجلس الشيوخ على حزمه المساعدات لاسرائيل
ونقلت ان بي سي عن السيناتور الديمقراطي
كروس ميرفي قوله ان تصريحات نتنياهو تؤدي
الى تعقيد المفاوضات بين الحزبين بشان
الحزمه التي تشمل مساعدات عسكريه لاسرائيل
فيما اكد سيناتور الديمقراطي بيتر ويلش ان
نتنياهو لا يشارك الولايات المتحده قلقها
بشان فقدان ارواح الفلسطينيين واضاف ان
رفض نتنياهو اقامه دوله فلسطينيه يكشف انه
يريد الاموال الامريكيه فيما يرفض دائما
نصائحها من جهتها وصفت السيناتور تامي
داكوورث تصريحات نتنياهو بالمفك اعتبر
سناتور براين تدز ان نتنياهو مخطئ
ويصعب الامور بالنسبه لمستقبل
اسرائيل